Speaker 1: Fox News continues to try to thread
this needle where they want to do what they
can to make someone other than Trump the Republican
nominee in 2024.
But Fox doesn't want to go off the deep end
off the diving board, so to speak, in case
Trump ends up being the nominee.
So some of the things Fox News has.
John just subtly and softly push voters and
public opinion towards Ron DeSantis include.
They'll do a man on the street segment.
And it just so happens that ten of the 11
people they talk to say, I would rather DeSantis
be the nominee than Trump.
Now, of course, you can talk to as many people
as you need to until you get enough to create
the narrative that you want.
And the narrative that Fox chose to create
was let's make these man on the street segments
overwhelmingly point to Republican voters
who prefer DeSantis over Trump.
They have been giving more sort of serious
positive coverage, or at least neutral coverage
to De Santos events than they have to trump
events.
Okay.
The latest thing is that they are straight
up running like a Ron DeSantis propaganda
special.
Here's the promo for it.
Take a look.
Fox Nation's hit docu series is back.
Who is Ron DeSantis?
We will never, ever surrender to the woke
mob.
He was in the Middle East advising SEAL Team
One to advise them.
You have to be the best of the best.
He's a.
Speaker 2: Good man.
He's a good husband.
He's a good father.
Is this Ron DeSantis his opportunity to run
for higher office?
I think it is.
Speaker 1: Who is Ron DeSantis streaming now?
Only on Fox Nation.
Yeah.
So anyway, remember what Angelo Carusone told
us about this?
Fox News primarily wants to be adjacent to
power.
And because it's not yet clear that Donald
Trump isn't going to be the nominee, Fox News
needs to continue at least plausibly setting
themselves up to fully jump back on on the
Trump train.
If Trump is indeed the nominee and if there
are potentially going to be another four years
of a Trump administration.
However, Rupert Murdoch doesn't think much
of Trump, and it's very clear from the released
text messages that we got last week that many
of the Fox News hosts don't really think much
of Trump, at least as far as his level of
honesty.
This includes Laura Ingraham, Sean HANNITY,
Tucker, etc.
Who knew Trump was lying all along about the
big lie and the entire thing?
So as Angelo told us when I interviewed him,
Angelo Carusone for Media Matters.
Fox News wants to do what it can to push voters
to Ron DeSantis or to anybody so that Trump
is less likely to be the nominee.
But they need to have a sort of eject button,
right?
They need to have an escape pod to get back
to Trump and not completely sever that relationship
because Trump is such a sycophant and he loves
because Trump is such a sycophant lover and
he loves suck ups.
Even though Trump is now criticizing Fox News
as being the Rhino Network and all of this
different stuff, if he is the nominee and
if Fox goes right back to him and, you know,
is eating out of his hand and whatever.
Trump will go right back to doing the prime
time Fox News interviews and the entire thing
because Trump loves the attention as well.
It's a sort of symbiosis of narcissism and
a symbiosis of narcissism and an obsession
with power that is going to keep that relationship
going if indeed Trump is the nominee.
But for the time being, subtly but increasingly
less subtly, Fox News is doing what it can
to hope that and and influence the Republican
primary towards someone other than Trump.
Right now, based on the polling, the best
contender, of course, would be Ron DeSantis.
And speaking of that polling, we've got a
few recent polls.
There is a coefficient poll which has de Santas
up 33 over Larry Hogan and Trump up 27 over
Larry Hogan.
So so like the Santos performing slightly
better than Trump against Hogan.
But DeSantis versus Trump, DeSantis is leading
by four.
However, in a Multi-way race, if you do.
Trump.
DeSantis.
Hogan, Nikki Haley, Mike Pence, Mike Pompeo,
Tim Scott, that's better for Trump.
And that is the trend in every single one
of these polls.
When the polls include more than just Trump
versus DeSantis, Trump tends to lead when
the polls are just Trump versus DeSantis.
It's much better for DeSantis in general.
So that continues to be a trend that, of course,
we are going
to follow.